we want to talk now to some of those
whistleblowers because yesterday three
FBI whistleblowers testified before
Congress and their allegations were
damning here is former FBI special agent
Steve friend have a look in August 2022
I made protective whistleblower
disclosures to my immediate supervisor
assistant special agents in charge and
special agent in charge about my
concerns regarding January 6
investigations and signed to my office I
believed our departures from case
management rules established in the
FBI's domestic investigations and
operations guide could have undermined
potentially righteous prosecutions and
may have been part of an effort to
inflate the FBI statistics on domestic
extremism the FBI weaponized the
security clearance processes to
facilitate my removal from active duty
within one month of my disclosures
in addition to an indefinite unpaid
suspension the FBI initiated a campaign
of humiliation and intimidation to
punish and pressure me to resign
in violation of HIPAA individuals at the
FBI leaked my private medical
information to a reporter at the New
York Times I pray that all members
considered the information I and my
fellow whistleblowers present you may
think I'm a political partisan you may
think I am a grifter you may think I'm a
conspiracy theorist it does not matter
simply put this committee should avoid
the temptation to impugn the character
and the motivations of The Messengers
seated before you
well joining us now with more of the
former the F former FBI whistleblower
you just heard from senior fellow at the
center for renewing America's Steve
friend Steve uh thank you for your
service and thank you for having the
guts to step forward and testify before
Congress having been one that asked the
questions I gotta tell you it's never
fun for somebody to come testify and I'm
sure they're probably coming after you
trying to impugn your character despite
your plea but tell us again from your
first hand experience how political the
Department of Justice has become as
opposed to that a body that's supposed
to you know have a blindfold on it and
treat everybody the same
I think it's very apparent that the way
they're selecting certain prosecutions
and we've seen examples of that with uh
with Mark hawk in Pennsylvania and
Philadelphia and that was an individual
standing outside of an abortion clinic
and selectively enforcing the face act I
think with the the latest Revelation
about the radical traditional catholic
memo that was generated from the
Richmond field office where they were
essentially choosing certain viewpoints
that are traditional marriage pro-life
probe water sovereignty those are all
viewpoints that are deemed to be
problematic and they're we're
essentially wrapping them in the label
of potential anti-government extremism
that is just code for Maga Republican
now the to hear it from the
administration here the president
himself he'll tell you that white
supremacy is the biggest terrorist
threat to the United States of America I
mean being there in the field as an FBI
agent is that true from your voice your
Vantage Point
that certainly wasn't the case for my
vantage point but I think that the the
callus has maybe grown a little bit
thick on the skin from people just being
called and labeled racist if they tend
to vote conservative and they're trying
to come up with this new and novel term
that essentially categorize them as
something that's problematic and that's
why you see two of the top four
priorities with the National Security
Branch of the FBI are anti-government
extremism and racial ethnic extremism
which is parenthetically white
nationalism and as far as the
president's concerned if you go back to
his speech at Independence Hall on
September 1st of last year those are the
two qualities that he tried to paint the
broad Rush of anybody who not just
supports former president Trump but
might even vote just generally the
Republican in the election yeah my
concern is that terrorism foreign
terrorism bio weapons other types of
things that may truly have feels like
we've taken our eye off the ball and
that's the concern real quickly Steve
what's the number one thing we can do to
help help reform the Department of
Justice and specifically the FBI
it's not about defunding federal law
enforcement it's about empowering local
law enforcement we should be looking to
deputize local detectives from Sheriff's
offices and police offices and those are
the folks that know what's going on in
Main Street and they're not going to be
so responsive to what the demands are
from K Street when they when they are
trying to address these crimes and bring
federal charges forward now well said
Steve friend I wish the best to you and
again thank you for your service and
thank you for joining us tonight on
Hannity we do appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else